is the expansion of space accelerating
if so will that acceleration reach the
speed of light if so what happens when
it reaches the speed of light it is
accelerating and over time it will one
day exceed the speed of light which it
can do because it's expanding space not
objects moving through space this is
allowed by Einstein's general theory of
relativity by raised in 1916 by Albert
Einstein and in so doing as the universe
expands faster than the speed of light
the objects that it puts beyond that
horizon will forever then be visible
from your view so the very distant
future all galaxies will accelerate
beyond your visible horizon and the
nighttime sky beyond our galaxy and our
entire known universe will just be the
stars in our nighttime sky sounds fine
it's still pretty far and all that we
know of and what we call cosmology will
no longer exist because we know
information about the rest of the
universe other than the stars that are
sitting in front of our net
[Music]